Good morning.
Yumeko!
What are you looking at?
This is...
She's an indie idol
and a member of the student council too.
Oh, I didn't know there was someone
like that on the student council.
Yumemi Yumemite.
She's a second-year student.
She's in charge of publicity.
She's gotten three million views
on YourTube,
and they say she's sure to make it big.
Sometimes, she does concerts at school,
but she's so popular, unless you're
in her fan club, you can't get in.
- You know a lot about her, huh?
- As a classmate, I want to support her,
- but the club fees are expensive.
- Thanks, everybody!
If you enjoyed it, click "like" and spread
the word! Share me with your friends!
Huh?
What's this?